hey I used to smile a lot I was strong
here on this picture I was 16 or 17 and
that's me with a friend here we were so
happy back then
Handan Ashkan enjoys looking at her old
pictures
she likes to remember her teenage years
but there's one person she's torn out of
all the photos her husband the men who
nearly killed her throughout the ten
years of our relationship he hit me he
beat me he insulted me wellhow Kyra
it happened in the bedroom - beauty goon
he - one day I will never forget it I
went to work with a black eye on split
lips I didn't want to get fired he
wasn't working but then hundun couldn't
take it anymore she wanted to leave her
husband there is video footage of what
happened next
one day he approached her with a gun and
shot her house she I thought this is it
I'm going to die I was on the ground
injured he put the gun in my mouth and
pulled the trigger but he had run out of
bullets
that was my second chance thank God for
two and a half years I have been
reliving that moment over and over again
I try not to let anyone notice neither
my children nor the people around me but
over and over in my dreams I see this
man trying to kill me since then handin
has been paralyzed from the waist down
her husband is in detention on paper
they're still married his trial for
attempted murder has been dragging on
for over two years
today there is another hearing her
brother said at a company's hundun to
court
she's actually entitled to a driver paid
by the municipality
hmm but that often doesn't work out
instead she takes a taxi
hundun hates these court dates the
prospect of having to see her husband
again scares her nr shaking he wants him
to receive the toughest punishment
possible five or ten years are just not
enough for what he put me through
reliable data on violence against women
in Turkey is scarce but what little does
exist suggests the numbers of rising the
women we talk to in Istanbul confirm
this yes we've all experienced abuse be
it physical or psychological cuddle my
own it's of course there's violence
against women here and reports on women
being murdered are increasing we're sick
of it my neighbor beats his wife I think
it's out of jealousy but it's a whole
different story when you ask men if I
saw something I'd intervene you know
culture women are the most precious
thing we have meeting a woman is wrong
Honda and said I'd have arrived at court
her lawyer is already waiting who are
dommage has represented many women who
have fallen victim to violence the
Turkish government stresses it's taking
the measure very seriously and recently
published this video Ellen mixes in the
message zero tolerance for domestic
violence nor the efficacy did RP steady
that there Nitin could the government
needs to do more to protect women than
release videos like this our society
dictates so much to women how they
should dress that being a housewife and
a mother is the best career for them
these are the messages our politicians
are constantly sending to the pcrc large
telephone I Emilio it's time for hundun
to enter the courtroom the trial against
her husband continues TV cameras are not
allowed inside the courtroom artist
captures the moment her husband is just
a few metres away from handin she tries
not to look him in the eyes the judge is
admitting a new psychiatric report as
evidence it confirms the defendants
criminal liability then the trial is
adjourned again
outside a few supporters are waiting the
activists regularly visit trials like
these their signs say you are not alone
Vanek or kyoto oma days are a long time
I was afraid but not anymore
my health has been ruined I probably
won't ever be able to live in happiness
and peace again that's why I say to the
women here in Turkey don't be afraid of
anything you are strong in a few weeks
handin will return when the trial
against her husband continues the man
who nearly killed her